[Music]
andrew is in burlington vermont andrew
get chris out of this for he gets in
trouble
hi gentlemen how are you doing today
great man what's up
um actually can i quickly say something
to nicole
yeah who was the previous caller um
nicole
i know this is a very tough time in life
um and i'm in a similar situation my
oldest
brother actually is a paranoid
schizophrenic
and my middle brother is a heroin addict
and that's
been rough but you can get through this
and make sure
you reach out for help for yourself
because it sounds like you're going to
have to be the rock
and if the rock is crumbling that's no
good for anyone so
make sure you're taken care of first
good work having been in a similar
situation
good words brother thank you said
earlier thank you um
but um so my heart was out to you um
so my question is i'm kind of suffering
from
uh paralysis from analysis okay
um so i i wasted my
20s to be honest i'm 32. i went my 20s
uh and not getting that compound
interest on investing or anything
um so i'm luckily enough now in the
debt-free position
um except for the house and i'm i'm
wondering
about um how to calculate risk
you know because keeping the mortgage
obviously as you guys
always been is a risk um but i'm i'm
trying to figure out
if i can split any extra money between
investing
and the mortgage and what a proper split
might be if that's okay
well everything's okay the question
around here
is what is the shortest distance between
you where you are
and wealth without taking on
extraordinary risk because extraordinary
risk is not the shortest distance it
catches you off guard
knocks you in the back of the head and
so you know that's where the baby steps
come from fifteen percent of your income
going into retirement
kids college if that applies is number
five and then six is we pay everything
else on the house so
are you asking about putting extra
beyond fifteen percent
towards the mortgage or towards the uh
into investments instead of towards the
mortgage
yes yeah so i'm i'm putting um actually
with the company match
it ends up being about 17 towards
retirement
we don't count company match in this in
that formula 15
of your income you put in and if the
company matches that's gravy on the
biscuit
that's extra okay so how much are you
putting into retirement
of your income i'm putting in 10 10 okay
it should be up to 15 plus your company
match then
and uh and then above that we put
everything on the mortgage
yeah so um yeah and i'm confused about
your question then if
you're asking above that should you just
keep investing instead of paying extra
on the mortgage is that what you're
asking
uh no so i'm already putting 150 extra
150 extra a month towards the mortgage
just you know kind of making that money
work for me ahead of time since the
mortgage is only
three years old at this point you know
but
um so i kind of was just trying to
figure out
um i guess i'm technically at
four months of savings now and then
anything above that
if i should split it between um the
mortgage and
investing again if i i didn't do any
investing
oh yeah no now you'd get yourself
up to your 15 like dave was saying
regardless of the company match and then
you anything extra you're attacking to
get this mortgage out of your life
okay and so you're 32 years young you're
going to be fine
uh you know i i think you you are trying
to vacillate back and forth between well
i could just keep my mortgage and try
to invest more that's what i'm hearing
if we were to sit down and unpack it
but no follow the steps do the 15 pay
the extra on the house
and then now that the how when the house
is out of your life now you can begin to
look at looking at bridge accounts and
some other things to do
to beef up your investing follow the
plan brother just stay allergic to debt
at 30 in the 30s that's where stupid can
creep in and you start to get that
deserved mentality you deserve a boat a
truck or motorcycle
avoid that and you're going to be fine
yeah good question thank you for joining
us and good words appreciate you sharing